okay
is this live are recorded
[Music]
hi mary beth hi there how are you
i'm great how are you good happy friday
oh my goodness thank you thanks
yeah thank goodness i like your hair it
looks cute oh thanks
you know the ponytail is always the
easiest thing to do
yes it is and it is cute
well thank you hey i had a quick
question for you
um one of the things that's it's not in
the questions and
answers that kara sort of drafted up for
us but it's newsworthy i mean i think
and so i wanted to bring it up in case
you're interested in talking about it
this week on the vegas chamber program
eggs and issues
that's usually in person but was virtual
this year this time
congressman amade told the vegas chamber
in our audience that he's considering a
run
for governor in 2022. oh i saw that i
saw you posted that
yeah yeah i definitely think so
if you wanted to to chat about that i
mean
we can talk about it i you know i don't
want to say anything that would
necessarily offend our current governor
but
it it certainly was um an interesting
announcement
yeah and that was during what was the
forum
it's an event that the vegas chamber
does called eggs and issues
okay and we it's always a forum for the
nevada delegation so this next
monday we have senator cortez masto oh
okay
cool yeah it's a regular thing that we
do and
you know traditionally it's been in
person it's it's a breakfast right eggs
and issues
um and we would do it at the four
seasons or
you know various places around las vegas
but now they're virtual as you might
imagine yeah okay
let me see okay congresswoman
okay i'm gonna add that
and then i think justin was mentioning
that um we rearranged the questions a
little bit but i'm
i'm good with however you want to do
that okay um they start with
um i want to just ask you about the
recent order
to cut capacity again and how you know
restaurants and bars have
been adjusting and then it goes uh it
goes through the shopping season and
then
it ends with the legislative session and
then i'll ask you about the exit issues
okay is that okay sure all right
whatever you want
you're in charge okay that sounds good
to me
all right mary beth well i'm getting the
green light are you ready to go
ready
all right four three
two well this has been a difficult time
for local businesses with
even more restrictions in just the last
couple of weeks so for a closer look at
the business community and how things
are going we welcome vegas chamber mary
beth
seawald good morning to you mary beth
it's great to see you
good morning alex it's great to see you
as well thanks for having me on
well thanks for being here i wanted to
start with this most recently governor
steve sisilak
ordered restaurants and bars to cut
capacity from 50 percent down to 25
percent
you know it's been a challenge for many
of them to stay open the past few months
as it was before so what impact is this
now having
well you know it's been a challenge
anything
that takes us backward is is a challenge
for
our businesses small medium and large
but you know i gotta hand it to them
everybody has been doing everything they
could to
comply and to adhere to
you know the restrictions and and the
face coverings
and the limited capacities and they're
really getting creative and they're
doing curbside
service curbside pickup but they're
really working hard to
stay at their capacities and you see the
video it's really
tough to see some of the empty bars and
restaurants that we're seeing
and they're trying really hard it's it's
devastating for some of our businesses i
have to tell you
and some of them are closing up shop but
they really are working hard to try to
comply
do you find the curbside and online
orders is that kind of making up for the
i guess it'd be now 75 percent uh
because those restaurants still have to
have all the staff members there the
chefs
uh you know in the meantime yeah you
know it is helping and we're encouraging
people especially through this holiday
shopping season
to to shop small shop local
because that really does help our small
businesses to survive and thrive
and you know when when you shop local
you are keeping people employed in our
community and it's so important to the
job market
and the local economy that we do shop
small and they're again they're getting
creative you know
if you you can go online for a lot of
our local small businesses
and and you can buy things online as
well and just have them shipped to you
so it's just so important especially
during the holiday season when
sales make up usually about 20 percent
of retails
retail sales for the whole year so for
small businesses
it's critical yeah absolutely you know
also in that same vein in the holiday
spirit
chamber has a great program called
switch to kindness the e-gift cards
how do those work mary beth yeah we're
really excited about that program
it's open to all local businesses as
long as they you can sign up
to be a chamber member and we're giving
away free memberships now so it doesn't
cost you anything to sign up
you can see there on the screen we have
tons of businesses who are participating
with that
you can go online at vegaschamber.com
select a business
select the amount and then enter the
recipient's email
and an e-gift card will automatically be
sent
it's a great way to send a gift to your
friends and family or
you can also purchase one for a first
responder which was one of the
original reasons that we came up with
the idea back in the beginning of covid
so switch to kindness is a great program
and it's super easy
yeah and going to support businesses too
you know we are nearly done with 2020. i
don't think anyone is upset about that
so mary beth what are you anticipating
for the upcoming year in terms of local
business you know it's not like a flip
is going to switch and everything's
going to go back to normal so
what do you expect to see well you know
it's going to be a continued effort to
keep the curve low it's going to be a
continued
effort to you know we're excited about
the potential vaccine that's coming out
now
that's going to be readily available in
the first quarter of the year and so
that'll significantly we think help us
get back to normal
you know in las vegas that means our
tourism and convention industry can
hopefully get back to being operational
special events like concerts and
sporting events can
can resume as well so we're looking
forward to that yeah fingers crossed
uh the 2021 legislative session that
starts here in about two months
what is the vegas chamber hoping to see
from lawmakers this session
well this session is going to be
critically important
probably our advocacy efforts at the
vegas chamber
are going to be more important now than
they've ever been
our state has some significant
challenges ahead
but we have to be mindful that the
number one thing we can do to get our
state back on track
is to focus on economic growth and the
vegas chamber is always on the lookout
for any legislation that might increase
regulations or
might cost businesses even more money at
a time when they really can't afford any
other burdensome regulations
you know those proposals would make it
harder to operate a small business and
and to keep people employed
so nevada's ability to provide services
to our residents
depends on businesses succeeding and so
we're hoping that legislators are going
to keep this in mind on every single
vote they take
you know and then think about will these
proposals
help employers or hurt employers will it
make it easier
or harder to keep their doors open so
those are the things we're focusing on
in 2021 especially as it relates to the
legislative session
yeah they need all the help they can get
uh mary beth i know you have eggs and
issues
a fun morning event uh and you had some
news uh from this previous event
from one of our congressmen yeah we did
uh eggs and issues is
one of our premier government affairs
events that we
put on at the vegas chamber about four
or five times a year
this one was virtual as you might
imagine and congressman
amade made the announcement so to speak
that he's considering
a run for governor in 2022. so
we were you know very interested and
excited that he made that announcement
uh through a vegas chamber program
and we'll wait and see if he actually
does decide to run or how that goes
it's hard to believe we have another
election coming up here in just two
years
so i'm sure a lot will happen between
now and then all right mary beth seawalt
it's great to see you thank you so much
for joining us
thank you alex you as well
thanks mary beth you are the bomb
thank you so much thank you did you have
a good thanksgiving
have an awesome day bye
you